[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing what may be a bit of a
controversial topic five things that
made james potter and draco malfoy the
same
now please hold your gasps i know this
may sound more than a little odd but if
we really dig into it these two
characters have far too much in common
to ignore so let's get started shall we
the first somewhat important similarity
between these two wizards is their
ancestral backgrounds yes as you may
know or have guessed both james potter
and draco malfoy came from pure blood
wizarding families although technically
if you go far enough back i guess you
could argue that the potter family
occasionally married a muggle or two and
anyone who knows anything about the
world of harry potter knows that the
malfoys strongly opposed mixing their
bloodline with poorer wizarding families
never mind muggles however you simply
cannot argue with the fact that both the
potters and the malfoys were strong
powerful wizarding families in their own
right after all james potter was the
descendant of ignotus peverell the first
known owner of the fabled invisibility
cloak from the tale of the deathly
hallows right so both james potter and
joco malfoy were from serious wizarding
families one arguably weak similarity
you may be thinking if that's all you've
got this is a joke but oh there is so
much more to start did you know that
both james and draco were only children
that's right neither james nor draco had
any siblings now i must admit that in my
experience some only children can be a
touch different not all only children of
course but if you think about it there's
not a lot of social assimilation for an
only child until they reach school age
meaning that for many of their formative
years an only child believes themselves
to be the center of well everything they
are quite obviously showered with all of
their parents attention and affection an
only child never has to share they never
have to prioritize caring for a sibling
over doing something fun and exciting
with their friends generally speaking
this can result in the establishment of
a very strong sense of entitlement and
privilege which more often than not is
just simply not possible for a child
growing up with brothers and sisters
this only child attitude is of course
incredibly obvious right from the start
in draco malfoy we see it almost
immediately when harry encounters him
for the first time in diagon alley in
the philosopher's stone he's rude
entitled and pays little attention to
those around him all of whom he clearly
sees as beneath him okay that's all well
and good you may be thinking but james
wasn't like that but wasn't he while
it's true that we get a very limited
view into what james would have been
like as a person we do get glimpses of
his behavior through both albus
dumbledore's pensive a magical device
used to store and review memories and
severus snape's memories which he takes
straight from his head and gives to
harry before he dies in the deathly
hallows of course memories like this do
need to be taken with a grain of salt a
memory is only as accurate as the
person's perception of the event that
said through various different scenes of
the past we tend to see time and time
again
james misbehaving if you were to ask
james's friends they would likely just
chalk this behavior up to james being
mischievous in nature but quite frankly
i think that's just an excuse for him
being in all honesty an entitled brat
mostly we see a school-aged james
picking on a young snape whom james
coldly referred to as snively not a very
nice nickname if you ask me it kind of
reminds me of the potter stinks badge
that draco so proudly wore in the goblet
of fire which is a perfect segue into
how james and draco are in fact both
bullies of course it's easy to see how
draco was a bully from the very
beginning of the series he was set up as
the antagonist to our hero harry not
only was he incredibly rude to harry the
first time they meet only to be
extremely friendly to him once he
discovered that harry was the harry
potter but over and over again we saw
him belittle wizards like ron weasley
simply for being as he puts it extremely
poor and terrorized witches like
hermione granger just for being
muggleborn he would even go out of his
way to put down multiple wizards at once
like in the philosopher's stone when he
said to neville long bottom if brains
were gold you'd be poorer than weasley
and that's saying something
obviously quite the bully but you may be
questioning if you could really call
james potter an outright bully well the
future lily potter did you think you're
funny she said coldly but you're just an
arrogant bullying toe rag potter leave
him alone i will if you go out with me
evans said james quickly go on go out
with me and i'll never lay a wand and on
snively again
not the most flattering interaction is
it james although clearly the more
well-liked wizard in school at least
according to those who knew him was
actually quite cruel to much less
popular snape why because he found out
that snape had feelings for lily evans
james's future wife in my opinion this
is absurd and clearly comes from a place
of insecurity as it's quite clear that
lilly isn't romantically interested in
snape and just values him as a friend
after all she's known him since she was
a child and severus was one of the few
people who understood her magic before
she did why then would james choose to
torment snape well i believe it was
because he could seeing severus as an
easy target who was beneath him james
didn't think snape even had the right to
have feelings for the same witch as he
did not so different from a young draco
malfoy who judged witches and wizards
based purely on their family's wealth
and bloodline i mean i think we can all
agree that eventually james outgrew this
terrible behavior which is likely how he
ended up with lily in the end but before
then he was well awful and quite
literally a bully
so yet another similarity between the
two wizards was that they were both
insecure we've just covered some of
james's insecurities so let's take a
look at a few of draco's of course they
were quite different from james's for a
variety of reasons where james was
concerned about popularity and girls
malfoy always seem to be trying to live
up to his father's expectations to be
the best worst kind of wizard especially
near the end of the series we frequently
see draco struggling with his
allegiances to the dark arts and
therefore his family and being a decent
person he certainly didn't seem
comfortable or confident about the
wizard he was expected to be
so what else did these two wizards have
in common well as you may recall while
at hogwarts both boys had what you may
call crews james was the ringleader of
his group of gryffindor friends which
was comprised of himself sirius black
remus lupin and peter pettigrew they
even name themselves the marauders which
means one who roams from place to place
making attacks and raids in search of
plunder definitely not the friendliest
of monikers but definitely fits the
bullying antics we've talked about
earlier draco of course had his
slytherin-only gang it was made up of
himself vincent crabb and gregory goyle
all of whom eventually became members of
the inquisitorial squad an exclusively
slytherin group put together by dolores
umbridge in the order of the phoenix
this group was meant to maintain order
among the students however they mostly
abuse their power using it to bully
students from rival houses what's more
the very word inquisitorial is quite
menacing as it brings to mind the
inquisition a group infamous for its
horrifying acts of persecution and
torture obviously not a very positive
affiliation so there you have it from
family status to the way they behaved to
personal qualities those are the five
ways in which james potter and draco
malfoy were the same were you at all
surprised by these similarities let me
know your thoughts or if you think i
missed any in the comments below as
always if you enjoyed the content i'd be
grateful if you liked it and subscribe
to the channel also happy to hear your
input on this and other harry potter
theories just leave those in the
comments as well until next time
remember happiness can be found even in
the darkest of times if one only
remembers to turn on a light
you